[Musique]
pearson a accru à ça on a pensé on se
disait surtout la génération qui
connaissait les allemands de la première
guerre mondiale
penser qu'on va nous obliger à
travailler l'allemagne a besoin de la
main d'oeuvre et on va travailler dur il
y aura beaucoup qui ne résisteront pas
mais on pensait pas à un massacre
techniquement scientifiquement organisé
alors moment tout cela se passe comment
vous invitons tous les jours au gâteau
la vie et l'été de plus en plus
difficile et je dois dire que c'est
surtout était tragique de se trouver
d'une part avec les enfants qui
n'avaient rien à manger rien à boire
rien s'habiller et lady moon s'est
promenée qui se mourait
j'ai visité un maison on peut pas
appeler ça une maison on l'appelait dans
l'est dans les ghettos on appelait sans
1.1.2 concentration c'était surtout des
enfants sans famille ou des enfants de
province qui sont venus là et j'ai vu
comment les enfants elle n'avait plus la
force des marchés de se promener et
qu'on les sorte et on les mettait cette
manne chemin au soleil et puis quand je
suis arrivé
l'après midi il y avait la moitié qui
qui était déjà mort c'était quelque
chose qui me restait jusqu'aujourd'hui
là je ne peux pas me débarrasser de
cette odeur qui se dégageait des enfants
morts vivants mourant l'idée qui préside
à la direction elle même est ce que
c'est vivre pour vivre comme cela il
vaut mieux mourir les armes à la main
c'est mieux comme ça c'était
insupportable et g
me suis entretenu un jour avec les
commandants en seconde de l'insurrection
de l'organisation juive de combat et il
m'a dit qu'il y avait une réunion
pendant laquelle les jeunes ont aussi
baisser les bras et le pessimisme les a
menés presque au suicide et il avait ne
savait pas comment s'est suicidé il
disait qu' on fera les derniers actes on
sortira des murs et on se battra avec
les allemands on avait pas d'armes mais
on sait on se masse rehaussé par à
massacrer mais ça sera une protestation
et c'est seulement superman qui s'est
opposé à cette idée des suicides et il a
commencé à demander à organiser une
résistance est la plus grande de joie je
crois d dans ces années sombres étaient
pour moi que demain bancaire les
premiers jours quand j'ai regardé par
les vasistas et j'ai pu voir dans la rue
vers 3 heures l'après midi les premiers
jours les 19 avril
des officiers des ss reculé avec des
mains tremblantes et ne sachant pas
comment tenir la mitraillette
c'était après qu'ils sont rentrés
toujours fier arrogants ils ont traité
des sous-hommes qui ne voulait même pas
nous tutoyer nous employer à un mot
qu'on emploie même pas pour les chiens
et quand on a vu les mêmes officiers ss
apeurée et puis s'est retiré et ne
savoir pas comment ces cachets contre le
mur que c'était la plus grande joie que
nous avons pu avoir les jours dès la
soirée des pétards commencer les soirs
mais quand vous repensez à tous les gens
qui sont restés là bas les hommes les
femmes les enfants vos amis votre
famille ça vous semble pas un peu
un peu irréel pour lui c'est pour moi
les souvenirs de ses amis de tema
famille lazard a fait que j'ai été
envoyé en dehors du camp en garde avec
un ss et je me suis trouvée séparer sans
même dire au revoir à tous qui mettait
les plus chers qui me reste est ce que
je ne peux pas parler des amis autrement
que c'était ma famille on vivait
ensemble on a souffert ensemble on n'a
pas compris les choses et on cherchait
une solution pour nous tous ensemble et
je garde toujours ici même les visages
qui me revient
que ce soit des irq al que ça soit des
mines à qui ça soit des hausses nappe
je peux
[Musique]